again our subject for this morning
if only you knew what did i say
if only and god spake all these words
saying
i am the law thy god which have brought
thee out of the land of egypt
out of the house of bondage thou shalt
have
no other gods before me thou
shalt not make unto thee any graven
image
or any likeness of anything that is in
heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or that
is in the water
under the earth thou shalt not bow down
thyself to them
nor serve them for i the lord thy god
am a jealous god visiting the iniquity
of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation
of them that hate me ensuing mercy
unto thousands of them that love me and
keep my commandments thou shalt not take
the name of the lord thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the law thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter
thy man's servant not thy maidservant
nor thy cattle nor thy stranger that is
within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth
the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day wherefore the
lord blessed the sabbath day
and hallowed it honour thy father
and thy mother that thy days may be long
upon the land which the lord thy god
giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery
thou shalt not steal thou shalt not bear
false witness against thy neighbor thou
shalt
not covet thy neighbor's house thou
shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant nor his maidservant
nor his ox nor his ass
nor anything that is thy neighbors
god is good god is good
and all the time happy sabbath everyone
it is an honor and a privilege to be in
the house of god
it is a double privilege for me to
fellowship with you this way
family members of missouri city baytown
laporte
and born again families wherever you are
i believe you're connected somehow i
cannot see you with the physical eye
but i see you with the eye of faith
because we must walk by faith and not by
sight
is there anyone present who is not a
seventh-day adventist
raise your hand uh would you
kindly stand tell us who you are yes my
good brother what's your name
curtis curtis how are you good to see
you where are you from
from here and curtis who invited you
and her name is who
lavert laverne
laverne thank you very much for bringing
this handsome man
even with the mask he's handsome so
we're grateful he's come
but the curtis please come again
sometime church if you agree say amen
say it again one more time
god bless you in every area of your life
i saw a hand to my right
ah what's your name chrysandra
how are you you look like a nice person
you are we're good good and god will
help you with that where are you from
cassandra
new orleans louisiana my wife is from
louisiana
she's a nice person too oh yeah she is
oh yes
now who invited you
where are they
somewhere around aha thank you very much
for coming
and may god bless you place his hand of
mercy upon your life
and never remove it say amen say it
again
one more time you may be seated my
lovely sister
now there may be someone in the church
that i cannot see where
where
oh hi my brother sorry for looking miles
beyond you how are you
what's your name
julian julian where are you from
from here all right and who invited you
oh good good good good but julian thank
you very much
i'm delighted to see you tell us the
name of the little angel in your arms
juliana god bless her how old is she
three jesus was three just like your
little girl
and as she rest so comfortably in your
arms let us realize this is how we
should rest in the arms of god
can you say amen god bless you god bless
your family
and god bless you so much that you
become a blessing to someone else
say amen say it again thank you my
brother please be seated
and hold tightly to that little angel
now if you're from
baytown laporte and you're not an
adventist thank you for coming i can't
ask you to stand
if you're from born again you're not a
seventh-day adventist thank you very
much i mean that with concentrated
seriousness
we're always privileged to have guests
among us
it is six minutes after that clock is
bearing false witness
it is six minutes after one after twelve
after one
after oh that thing says two or seven
this is a place of truth not lies
i'll try to finish as soon as i can i
leave that up to the spirit of god
but a pastor may the lord bless your
work with the church
acts 2 47 and the lord added to church
daily
such as in all whenever you do god's
work remember
the power that changes a life is the
power of god
the power that convicts a person of sin
is the power of god
and the power that tells the devil back
up is the power
of god we're just instruments in his
hands
we are the wires through which divine
power flows
thank you pastor for the honor of
occupying this sacred desk
i'm really grateful somewhere i read in
elohim's writings
angels occasionally ask god to let them
preach
and he tells them no he reserves that
for people made of dirt such as i
and so i am aware that as i stand in
this pulpit
i am doing something angels are
eager to do and so i thank god
we will be here for two weeks i hope
you'll come
bring your friends try to bring your
enemies as well and let the gospel make
them your friends
because the gospel makes us friends to
god we're enemies of god by nature
i didn't say god is our enemy we are
enemies of god by nature
romans 5 10 while we were enemies
we were reconciled to god by the death
of his son much more being reconciled we
shall be saved by his life
so the gospel changes enemies into
friends
so bring them if you cannot bring them
pray for them but remember that god is
not willing that any should perish
thanks again our subject for this
morning if only you
knew what did i say
if all you knew before i get into the
message do three little things for me
they're quite simple one
preserve reverence where you are the
fact that when the church building does
not automatically mean that people are
referent
um god has allowed me to travel the
world
and sometimes we're not very referent in
god's presence
but preserve reference god likes that
and for those of you watching online
wherever you are youtube facebook
zoom whatever it is god's holiness does
not change because
your connection is electronic god is
holy
whether in the desert with moses in the
inner court of the high priest
or on zoom god is holy
and appreciates respect are you with me
so make sure that you are giving that
reference to god
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth that
request is based on jeremiah chapter 1
verse 9
which says then the lord put forth his
hand and
touched my mouth and the lord said unto
me behold
i have put my words in thy mouth
and the words of the lord are powerful
words after all they created
heaven and earth my words have no power
so i'll keep my opinions to myself and
give you thus
saith the lord so from time to time say
that prayer
on my behalf and favor number three
i want you to think as you listen yes i
said
think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together
we serve a reasonable garden
the devil is unreasonable god
is reasonable and so he says come now
let us
reason together jeremiah 12
5 if thou has run with the footmen
and they have weary thee how then canst
thou contend with the horses
god is a reasonable god use your common
sense
if you cannot keep up with a man how do
you plan to keep up with the horse
much of religion is common sense guided
by the spirit
of god somebody say a man for common
sense
all right if you're going to the gym to
lose weight and after three months
you're 15 pounds heavier
but stop and think something is not
working are you with me
stop reason something is not working
all right let's pray father in heaven
thank you for life thank you god
for freedom of worship thank you for
clear minds we're not in mental
institutions
thank you father we're not imprisoned
thank you to god for health and despite
all the problems and trials we may have
we thank you that we're still able to
come to your house
god we thank you for that function of
blood that still flows
because of that forgive us where we've
sinned
particularly me cleanse me to god that i
might be a clean vessel for your use
father in heaven bless our guests who
came to be with us
in a very special way in this physical
building and in the other churches that
are connecting now
put your words in my mouth there god
speak through me father
let me simply be an instrument in your
hand i offer no resistance
and god let the spirit speaking through
me
be the selfsame spirit enlighten your
people
and if anyone listening to me that god
has contracted the coronavirus
i ask you in the name of jesus who
healed everyone who came to him
touch that person their god just to be
merciful
because your word says he maketh his son
to rise
on the evil and on the good and sendeth
rain
on the just and on the unjust send the
sunshine of your merciful healing
send the raindrops of your favorite god
and heal those afflicted persons now
dear god
we commit this service to your glory and
your glory alone
i pray from my heart in jesus name let
god's people say
amen and amen what's our subject
if only you knew john chapter 4
reading from verse 7 i read from the
king james version of the bible
john 4 reading from verse 7.
this is the seventh-day adventist church
don't take long to find the text
have you found it john 4 verse 7
there cometh a woman of samaria to draw
water
jesus saith unto her give me to drink
for his disciples were gone away unto
the city
to buy meat then saith the woman of
samaria
unto him how is it that thou
being a jew oscars drink of me
which i'm a woman of samaria for the
jews have
no dealings with the samaritans
jesus answered and said unto her now
listen carefully to what jesus said
if thou knewest the gift of god
what's our subject if only you knew
and who it is that saith unto thee give
me to drink
thou would have asked of him and he
would have given thee
living water read first
again microscopically
jesus answered and said unto her
if thou nourished the gift of god
meaning the woman was ignorant
because she did not know who jesus was
that's why she said what she said in
verse nine
how is it the thou being a jew ask his
drink of me which i'm a woman of samaria
for the jews have no dealings with the
samaritans she said that
because she did not know christ or god
a lot of racial tensions result from the
fact that two groups do not know each
other
there is no interaction at schools on
the job wherever
in the playground and consequently
there's mutual suspicion
because i don't know you i miss
behave and vice versa if
thou knewest the gift of god
and who it was that saith unto thee
give me to drink thou would have asked
of me
and i would have given thee living water
it is essential that we know god i was
but i often encounter people
who are angry with god and are about to
leave him
and as i frequently say i have yet to
meet someone who is angry with the devil
and is about to leave him
when things go wrong we leave god
the question becomes when you leave god
where are you going
when you leave god to whom are you going
and people
leave god generally because they do not
finish my words for me no god what's our
subject
if thou knowest john 17 verse 3
and this is life eternal that they might
know thee the only true god and jesus
christ whom thou has sent
we do not know god we do not
know jesus we do not know the holy
spirit or we do not
understand them as much as god would
have us
understand them if we would understand
god we would realize
that god does everything for our good
let's see how far back god had you in
mind
matthew 25 reading from verse 31
our subject if only you knew
what book did i say what chapter
reading from what verse very good
do you have it
nobody answered the preacher there you
have it okay
all right let me pray again holy father
please help me possess me
completely that my voice becomes your
voice
in jesus name i pray amen
when the son of man shall come in his
glory
and all the holy angels with him then
shall he sit upon the throne
of his glory and before him shall be
gathered
all nations and he shall separate them
one from another
as a shepherd divideth his sheep from
the goats
and he shall set the sheep his sheep on
the right hand and the goats
on the left now 34 read microscopically
then shall the king say unto them where
on his right hand come ye blessed of my
father
inherit the kingdom come on prepared for
you finish the verse
from the foundation of the world
that's before you were born
come thou blessed of my father
enjoy something i
prepared for you before
finish my words you were born
listen to revelation 13 verse 8 and all
that dwell upon the earth shall worship
him
whose names are not written in the book
of life of the lamb finish the verse
slain come on from the foundation of the
world
god had you in mind before you were born
and all his thoughts were your good
jeremiah 1 reading verses 4 and 5
then the word of the lord came unto me
saying before i
formed thee in the belly i knew thee
i want you to understand there is a god
who has been thinking of you and has
planned a life for you
before you were born and every step in
that life
is a blessed step
god thinks no evil towards anyone
come on say amen well let the bible say
then you may say amen
jeremiah 29 verse 11 for i know the
thoughts i think the words you said the
lord come on thoughts of
good and not of evil come on to give you
an expected end or a hope and a future
the thoughts
i think towards you says god are
not evil even with the liquor
in your hand my thoughts are not evil
even with the condom in your wallet
my thoughts toward you are not evil with
the drugs coursing through your veins
my thoughts toward you are not evil
and if you understood that it may change
your behavior
on that cross while christ was
suffering what had just been done to him
he looked at the people who had just
done it and he prayed
father forgive them come on
for they know not what he is looking out
for the good
what's our subject if only
you knew what a genesis one
god is a good god somebody say amen
psalm 100 verse 5
for the lord is good
that's his habit he can't be anything
else but good
by the way even when he destroys sinners
he'll be good
genesis 1 reading verse
do you have that but you shouldn't have
to go there come on
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth now that is a summary
statement let's look at some details
on day one what did god make decide too
slow
that side light
on day two this side too slow that side
no firmer day three
that side i come back to you in mercy
day three
vegetation what's wrong with you day
four
don't hesitate sun moon and stars day
five
day five fishing birds
day six land animals and
humanity now don't let me down day seven
now listen to verse 31
do you have it and god saw
everything that he had made finished for
me
and behold it was very good
that is a setting into which he placed
adam and eve the environment
was very good the source of food
was very good the marriage arrangement
he conducted
was very good the face-to-face
communication
he enjoyed was very good god
looked out for the good of adam
and eve
and he has not changed
god could have made adam on day one
before food was made
are you with me food was made on day
three the fruit trees
he could have made him on day one he
made it on day six
when the oxygen he needed was in place
the beauty of the land the flowers the
grass was in place
the sunlight was in place food was in
place
everything necessary was in place then
god made him why
because god always looks out for your
good
there are no exceptions
not is john 6
john 6 our subject if only you knew
is 23 minutes after 12.
i'll let you down and let you out as
soon as i can
of a church family at uh baytown laporte
and
born again we're with you and i know
you're with us
what book did i say john what chapter
6 reading for what verse i didn't give
it verse 5
that man is paying attention verse 5
before i go on
let me pray again father continue to
direct this service to your glory
exclusively and also for our blessing
in jesus name i pray amen when jesus
then lift up his eyes
and saw a great company come unto him he
saith unto philip
when shall we buy bread that these may
eat now read verse six with me
and this he said to prove him come on
for he himself knew
what he would do when did christ know
what he would do
before the crisis
there is a crisis waiting for you
perhaps this week
are you following me apply john 6 6 to
your life
god already knows what he'll do but you
and i
have to cooperate
he himself knew what he would do
let's look at hardship and see how
hardship is used by god
for our good deuteronomy chapter eight
let's read from verse one our subject
if you only knew or if only you knew you
can choose the arrangement you like
what book did i say what chapter
reading for what verse one
the first five books were written by
moses so when jesus talks about moses
he usually referring to the first five
books
you have deuteronomy 8 all the
commandments which i command you this
day shall he observe to do
that you may live stop let's look at
that a digression
listen to the words again all the
commandments which i
command thee this they shall you want
observe what does that mean give me one
word for that
obey now here is the result of obedience
keep reading
that you may live stop
obedience is life
ah i'm talking to myself obedience
is life so jesus said i am come
that they might have life
first timothy chapter 5 verse 6 she that
liveth in pleasure or he
is dead while he liveth there is a way
to be physically alive but in every
other way
dead there is a life only christ can
give
and so the bible says all the
commandments which i
command thee this day shall he observe
to do
that he may live
and multiply and go in and possess the
land which i swear unto your fathers
verse two and thou shalt remember all
the way
which the lord thy god led thee these 40
years in the wilderness to do what
to humbly come on and to prove thee to
know what was in thine heart stop
have you ever seen a pneumatic drill and
fixing the road these guys are this is
that's the
the thing is hard so you need a
pneumatic drill you can't use a little
thing you use in your garden
you need a pneumatic drill that's the
way the caramel nature is
and god has to drill through it
so he uses hardship sometimes but it's
for our good
and he humbled thee and suffered into
hunger
and fed thee with manna wish thou
knewest not
neither did thy fathers know that he
might make thee know we're in verse 3
that man what doth not live by bread
only
but by every word that proceedeth out of
the mouth of god
now let's go to verse 16.
we just read in three he humbled thee
suffered the hunger all right verse
three
who fed thee in the wilderness with
manna
which thou thought thy fathers knew not
that he might
humble thee that's verse 16 that he
might to do what
prove thee finish the verse to do the
good come on
at thy latter end the purpose
of the trials in the wilderness
were for the good of the israelites
i have never heard of a pleasant
surgical procedure
i've never heard of a delightful
injection
it was for the good
if only you knew that god always
acts for the good of his people
and that's you go to jeremiah 24.
jeremiah 24 we read verse 5.
jeremiah 24 reading verse 5 i was
subject if only you knew
jeremiah is addressing a people under
the thumb of nebuchadnezzar
and god told them submit to
nebuchadnezzar by the way
god was very serious submit to him
because he's my servant that's what god
said
in chapter 27 of uh jeremiah
thus saith the lord the god of israel
like these good things so will i
acknowledge
them that are carried away captive in
uh of canaan of um judah
whom i have sent out of this place into
the land of the chaldeans
first the verse for the good
god is always acting for our salvation
he sent them into captivity
for the good
god may take your job for your good
young man wrote me this morning very
nice fellow
on the other side of the world i'm
losing my confidence in god
his promises no longer mean anything to
me and
praying seems useless and statements
like that
and i wrote back to him and i said what
was your point for praying
and what was your point for believing
the promises
why do you pray to god as a means of
controlling god's behavior
so that god does whatever faith is not
believing god will do whatever i say
faith is believing god will do whatever
he says
let me say that again faith is not
believing
god will do whatever i say faith is
believing god will do whatever
he says
let me show you how good god is
what i'm about to say is a little harsh
but i'll say
but it's biblically harsh
god owes you okay
there you go you saved me from the
guillotine god owes you
come on nothing but he wants to give you
we pray as if god is indebted to us
let me say it again god owes me
and you nothing
but death that's what we deserve are you
with me
through christ he has given us
everything
because god says i know the thoughts i
think the word you set the lord
thoughts of peace and not of evil
to give you an expected end a blessed
future a hope
something to look forward to god is
always
looking out for the good of his people
for the good of everyone
when god called abraham god had
more than abraham in mind he had the
good of the world
because god cannot think evil are you
with me
let me tell you god cannot entertain
evil thoughts
go to genesis 12 let's read from verse
one
our subject if only you knew genesis
chapter one
reading for what verse the verses we're
about to read are about the most
some of the most significant verses in
the entire bible
in my humble assessment
you have genesis 12 nobody answered the
preacher again this is becoming a habit
what verse did i say we begin with one
now the lord had said unto abram
get thee out of thy country and from thy
kindred
and from thy father's house unto a land
that i will show thee
and i will make of thee a great nation
and i will bless thee
and make thy name great and thou shalt
be come on
a blessing keep reading now and i will
bless them that bless thee come on
and curse him that curse of thee and
in thee finish the verse shall all
families
of the earth be blessed when god called
abraham
god has the world in mind
because god is always looking out
for your good
because that's the way he is
and so jesus said to that woman at the
well
if thou newest the gift of god
if you knew who i am
where i came from what i represent
why i'm here and come tonight to find
out why jesus came come tonight
you would have asked me for water and i
would have given you water from which
you would never thirst
my brothers and sisters we do not know
god as we ought do this little
experiment for me
on your own time go to a concordance
look at the word ignorant in the new
testament particularly
and see how many times you read i would
not have you
to be ignorant then look up the word no
k-n-o-w
how many times paul says what do you not
know do you not know
do you not know no shall not
my people are perished or they perish
why for
lack of knowledge
and the lack of knowledge that destroys
us is a lack of the knowledge
of god and his love for us and so the
bible says
for god so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
that whoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life
now god had one begotten son
and he gave him christ
was not loaned to the world
finish my words
christ is not alone come on
he's a gift permanent
now when god gave christ god had nothing
else
he gave the creative heaven and earth he
gives someone equal with himself
he give not only the one who created he
give the one who sustains creation
when god gave christ he gave everything
he had nothing left
for god so loved the world now let's
look at god's goodness again
when god made heaven and earth genesis 1
at the end of creation week was god dead
or alive
alive which means it did not
cost the life of god to create
heaven and earth ah you're not with me
you're with me it did not cost god
his life yes he gave of his life
to creation he did not give up his life
for salvation
are you with me for salvation
god gave up his life
through his humanity because divinity
can't die
but god had to find a way to die he
became human and by that avenue he gave
up his life and so jesus told john the
revelator
in revelation 1 18 i am he that liveth
and was dead
listen carefully to me let me pray again
father as i slide the downward slope of
this message
tighten your grip on my faculties in
jesus name i pray
amen here is creation
here is salvation let me modify my words
here is
creation here is you
it cost more to save you
than to create the universe
is a god looking out for your good
if only you knew
let me say it again it cost
god more to save one person
than to create heaven on earth
why do i say one what man of you having
a hundred sheep
if he lose come on one of them does not
leave the mighty nine in the wilderness
and go
after that which was lost until he find
it in other words when he found it
it's just the shepherd and the sheep
salvation is not a crowd affair it's a
one-on-one affair
jesus died for you
it's nice of you to think he died for
the person next to you
he died for you
personally so when i say it costs more
to save you
than to create the universe i am talking
to you
mind character and personality volume 2
page 4 23 paragraph 2
the gospel deals with individuals
each person has an individuality
distinct and separate
from all others everyone has a soul to
save or to lose
each must believe for himself repent for
himself be convicted for himself
be converted for himself jesus christ
had your good in mind and he died for
you
if only you knew
that there's a god in heaven who is
always looking out
for your best when you understand that
can you trust a god like that yes
if you've got a friend who's borrowing
money and always refusing to pay
moving to another city can you trust
that person
no if someone donates a kidney to you
can you trust that person yes
the bible says we love him finish my
words because come on
he first loved us
god could have put upon us an
impossibility show me your love first
then i will respond
but a carnal person cannot show love as
god requires it
so god's acts first that's another thing
to know about god
god must act first and i'm coming to the
end
listen to genesis not genesis john 3 16
for god
so loved the world that's before the
world was made
that he gave his only begotten son
that's before adam sinned
god acts first
and as i said always for our good my
brother
my sister there is a god
who has a personal interest in your life
right where you sit and he wants to
redirect your life
in a path he has laid out for you will
that path have
trials yes would it have tribulations
yes but they're designed to finish my
words
for your good
football players will tell you i've
never you listen to them on interviews
they don't like training camp
or basketball play because it's rough
it's hard
you work hard getting ready for the
regular season it's hard but
it's for their good
when someone suffered a stroke and has
to learn to walk again
it's hard are you following me on the
walk between these two bars and
but they do it they do it and then the
walking ability returns
but the attempt was hard but it was for
their
good
we serve a god who always looks out
for our good and i'll tell you something
and i'll close here is jesus
here's you who went to the cross
jesus that you might not have to go
let me say differently you did not get
what i said
christ in gethsemane he sweat blood from
his skin
it was so rough god had to send an angel
luke 22 43
to strengthen him because he almost went
back
that's what we deserve
but he put it on jesus because he's
looking out
for your good.
what did christ see on the cross my god
my god come on
now jesus didn't lie the father forsook
him for a while
but the father had a choice for saint
jesus
or forsake you
for god so loved the world come on
here's the world here his son for god so
loved
the world personalize that for god so
[Music]
whether you have no education you go to
the welfare office for food stamps it
makes no difference to god
he loved you so much he gave up jesus
now the only way to please god is by
faith can you believe that
that god has your best interests at
heart
you know your parents do
what about god let me close
i know the thoughts i think towards you
seth the lord
finish the verse for me thoughts of
peace not of evil
to give you an expected end or a hope
and a future there is a god
who is always looking out for your good
and if
only you and i knew that it would change
our behavior
towards him for we love him because
he first loved us how many will stay
with me father
thank you for looking out for my best
interest can i see your right hand
my best interest can i see that stand up
with me
they'll ask you to do a favor for god
not for me for god
we are on the edge of a serious time of
trouble
i have ceased to grieve very much
because of funerals
because i've known from the bible in the
writings of our servant ellen white
god is putting his people to sleep
because they will not be able to endure
what's coming
so if god and his mercy put my mother to
sleep i'm not fussing with god
are you following me and there's a lot
of death in the attitude someone wrote
me
an ornament from where a lot of the
members are dying god is putting
them to sleep
because the times that coming upon us
will be hard
but you see we are preparing for life in
a world
where sin will never rise again
so we have to decide now
with all our heart and soul come on
and mine and strength i want nothing to
do with sin
so god can seal that and it will last
for eternity and beyond
jesus said thou shalt love the lord thy
god with all thy heart with all thy soul
with all thy mind
with all thy strength now
who would like to recommit the life to
god and say father
in so far as i can i recommit
my life to you with all my heart and
soul can i see your right hand
i recommit my life to you as far as i
can
hands down head bowed father
we can only go so far in our humanity
but we thank you today god in your mercy
you make up for our shortcomings
we stand to say we recommit our lives to
a god
who always has our good in mind
father you have no evil thoughts
toward us first corinthians 13 verse 5
thinketh no evil dear god
forgive us for questioning your love
forgive us their god for
doubting your desire to save us even
though we frequently say
the lord is not willing that then he
should perish
in the name of jesus dear god forgive us
for lack of faith
forgive us for saying one thing but
living differently
and having heard the message if only you
knew the god we have recommitted our
lives to you
and father day by day through the power
and ministry of the word
let us hold tightly to you knowing that
whether it rains or it
shines or it snows or it floods you
have our best good in mind
ah god hasten the day when this desire
for our good
will flourish into a place in your
eternal kingdom
until then keep us faithful
today i pray for my heart in jesus name
let god's people say amen and amen you
may be seated